[Music]
far away as north as we can go once
stood an enchanted forest you see an
enchanted forest yes it was a magical
place but something went wrong since
then no one can get in or that was
paddock what would I do without you
you'll always have me
[Music]
how's Elsa seemed weird to you she seems
like Elsa there's this voice voice what
does that mean
the kingdom is not safe find who is
calling to you they may have answers I'm
going with you
Anna no excuse me I climb to the North
Mountain survived two frozen heart and
saved you from my ex-boyfriend so you
know I'm coming
it's normally
where are we
how'd it get in the forest the mist
parted for us impossible
where did you learn magic
I can't just follow me into fire don't
run into fire
[Music]
magic is very alluring without you see
they use herself
protect arendelle at all cost
[Music]
I believe in you also more than anyone
or anything
[Music]
quick question is the whole putting up
the mortal danger gonna be a regular
thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Elsa the past is not what it seems
you must find the truth
across the enchanted lands and into the
unknown
but be careful
we have always feared houses powers were
too much for this world
[Music]
now we must hope
[Music]
they are enough
[Music]
I won't let anything happen to her
[Music]